toulouse ce matin la caravelle spéciale
à madame monsieur kossyguine vient de se
poser sur l'aérodrome de toulouse
blagnac
que valait un vent froid le président du
conseil soviétique en laissant
accompagné par monsieur pompidou puis
ministre par monsieur christian fouchet
ministre de l'éducation nationale et il
passe en revue les troupes qu'il y
rendent les honneurs
et
remise de fleurs par les ballets occitan
en costumes folkloriques discret rappel
du grand passé de toulouse vieille et
charmante cité mais aussi ville jeune en
pleine expansion est prise d'avenir
comme nous allons nous en rendre compte
tout de suite nous allons nous en rendre
compte
ici à la faculté des sciences de
rangueil ou plutôt au complexe
scientifique de rangueil qui échoue sur
160 hectares c'est bâtiment ultramoderne
où l'on mène de pair l'enseignement et
la recherche
et où sont aussi logés les étudiants
complexe qui sera bientôt flanqué du
complexe aérospatiale de l'espine et
qu'il deviendra là les plus importants
d'europe occidentale
les étudiants en fallut ont un bel
accueil à me chicaud sigle après quoi on
écoute le discours du recteur de
l'université monsieur loyen l'université
qui vous accueille
monsieur le président est l'une des plus
anciennes de france plus anciennes même
que la sorbonne
puisque notre acte de naissance remonte
à 12 129
cette université très vieille est aussi
très jeune la preuve c'est l'ambiance
joyeuse à rien chahuteuse si j'ose dire
et fort sympathique en tout cas dans
laquelle les étudiants escorte monsieur
kossyguine tandis qu'une parcours à pied
une petite partie des terrains et des
bâtiments et monsieur kossyguine comme
vous le voyez visiblement satisfait de
cet accueil juvénile et maintenant voici
le capitole autrement dit la mairie de
toulouse
nous entrons dans un instant la foule
souhaitait la bienvenue à sa façon mais
écoutons tout d'abord le maire de la
ville monsieur base à ces pressions aux
études les plus poussées dans les
domaines de l'aéronautique de
l'électronique est au niveau le plus
élevé bientôt de l'aérospatiale le
chercheur participe d'ailleurs au
programme commun franco soviétique
et le voici aux usines de sud aviation
qui sont un peu le symbole de
l'expansion de la nouvelle toulouse
monsieur kossyguine sous la direction du
général qg président de sud aviation
accompagner toujours par monsieur
pompidou et également par monsieur
messmer ministre les armes et visites
différents hélicoptères fabriqués par
sue l'aviation de la petite alouette aux
gros super frelon et puis l'on s'en va
dans les bâtiments où se fabriquent
concorde les normes avion supersonique
franco-britannique visite dans les
bureaux d'études d'abord puis à
l'atelier où le prototype 001 est en
cours d'assemblage très avancées déjà
puisque le premier vol est prévu au
début de 1968 le travail se poursuit
pendant qu'on attend monsieur costing
le président du conseil soviétique
visiblement intéressé se fait expliquer
les détails de cet appareil
révolutionnaire puis il pénètre dans les
entrailles du monstre
il pose quelques questions équipe qui
travaille qu'à l'intérieur va d'un bout
de l'appareil à l'autre repart revient
et finalement ils leur sort par la porte
principale
nous étions quelques-uns à l'attendre au
pied de l'appareil
son impression sur le concorde
pascaline facilitateur concorde
c'est un énorme travail je prends un
très vif intérêt cet appareil bien sûr
pour l'instant le travail n'est pas fini
mais je souhaite un plein succès aux
constructeurs
parfois je les concordes la vache tout
pour la sto sarac city reste que le
concorde ressemble à votre type relève
144 takoué son petit caniche qui
remplace ce sont des questions délicates
et technique qui relèvent des
spécialistes et les spécialistes les
expliquerons mieux que moi
laissons vente monsieur kossyguine
quitté concorde le monstre supersonique
est monté dans une autre production de
sud aviation une caravelle pour aller à
son étape suivante c'est à dire vers
lyon